you used to get a floppy disk on the
cover of a magazine with some software
on it and if you're really lucky you get
a really old game that no one wanted to
play free on the cover of the magazine
now you can walk into the shop and
purchase a magazine with a free computer
on the front the Raspberry Pi was
developed by the Raspberry Pi foundation
is a sort of cheap general-purpose
computer that could be used to teach
people how computers work so the aim was
to sort of try and recreate the home
computer boom that was around in the
early 80s and they took the naming
convention from the BBC micro to set up
with the model B and the model a and
then just like the BBC micro I went to
the model B plus we have here they
brought out the model B plus of the
Raspberry Pi I've got nice aero USB
ports Ethernet port to connect to the
network HDMI out so you can plug into
your telly and USB for a standard mobile
phone charger the last Thursday on
Twitter saws was getting up in the
morning that they released a new one the
Raspberry Pi 0 and the first thing that
immediately hit you was the price five
dollars less than the price of a movie
ticket at the local cinema and they
looked down a bit further on Twitter and
I realized that they were giving them
away on the cover of a magazine that's
how small is compared to the floppy disk
what are we giving up to have such a
cheap piece of kit it's at least as
powerful as the original Raspberry Pi
you can it up to a one gigahertz it
comes with 512 Meg of RAM
it's about equivalent to a typical
desktop or laptop machine in the
mid-2000s in terms of CPU speed so what
have we actually got here what have we
got on it well we've got a microSD slot
where we can put in an operating system
and I've burnt one onto a SD card
earlier so we should be able to boot it
up we've got mini HDMI out to connect it
to your TV so you need a mini HDMI to
normal HDMI connector we have a USB port
so you can plug some peripherals in and
we have a power socket on a USB port and
that's about it the other thing we've
got is a row of holes where we can
solder in connectors to access the GPIO
port so we can connect you up to other
things like I did last year with the
Christmas tree so let's connect it up
and see what happens I've got an HDMI
connector to this screen here is it lat
we've got there so no it's not a laptops
this was developed by Motorola for the
Atrix line of mobile phones and the idea
was that you documoto in the back and
then be able to use it as if it was a
little computer but don't you ever
really took off but they're great for
connecting things together you've got
HDMI input and USB connections to the
keyboard and mouse you need a few
converters to make it all work but it's
great for sort of hacking with little
things like raspberry PI's so we've got
the HDMI connected to it to a mini HDMI
socket and this is where things get a
little awkward the USB connector is a
micro USB connector the sort you
normally use to charge your mobile phone
but it's being used this to connect
peripheral so you need to get hold of a
converter before you can use this you're
going to spend more than four quid
because you're going to need to buy the
converters unless you've already got
them I sort of fashioned my own out of a
bit of an old motherboard the cable of
my digital camera and some paper clips
but anyway it seems to it serves the
purpose so in connector for the keyboard
and mouse built into here very out
that's connected up and the only thing
that's left is to connect the power we
should see it start to boot up and
you'll see the flashing lights there we
go and then on the actual screen we can
see Linux booting up and I've already
configured this so it should in a minute
boot me to the desktop and we can start
using it as a normal computer it's got
to be a drawback there's got to be
something and I don't mean is readily
negative but so in terms of using it I
mean once you get started running the
raspbian environment you can use it like
any other Raspberry Pi if you're
teaching you get hold of one of these
and for four quid give everyone in your
class their own computer to do some
computer science stuff on it relatively
easy to set up the instructions for
setting up the SD cards are dead easy to
set up and if they destroy it well at
that price it's probably not much more
expensive than the exercise books
they're writing in any way or the
textbooks they're working from so it's
effectively disposable I think so what
sort of things can we do with it well it
comes with some software built in this
and programming environments there's a C
compiler in here as well as some Java
stuff python scratch and so on so
standard Raspberry Pi environments all
they're the major feature that's missing
and I haven't mentioned it yet is
networking by default there is no
connection to the internet on there you
can't plug it into an Ethernet there's
no Wi-Fi so if you want to take it
online then you'll need some sort of
adapter so I'm using a USB to Ethernet
adapter to connect it to the network and
so that works very well so if we run a
web browser hopefully that will start up
in a second
these machines are roughly about the
power of the early 2000s but they're
good fun to play with so they might be
slower than what you used to day-to-day
but yeah it's slower than your typical
Mac or PC I suppose it'll be a bit
churlish to say it's a bit slow
considering it costs five dollars I mean
it depends what you need it for I mean
it's fast enough to do some things but
other things you'd probably want
something more powerful I mean you could
stick it behind your TV and use it to
watch movies if you put a Wi-Fi dongle
on it and stream video to it so what
statistic is coming up with YouTube is
it yep let's come up with YouTube I
think the reason is too low is I have a
very dodgy adapter here which doesn't
seem to work the keyboard keeps cutting
out as well so don't try this is a view
of the speed so yeah you are going to
have to buy some adapters and if you've
got a keyboard a monitor you need one of
them but it is a fully functional
machine if you were to learn how to
program or perhaps learn how to do
hardware hacking you've got the GPIO
pins here which you can solder on some
adapters and then you can connect you up
to devices so like I did the Christmas
tree last year you could create one
using this and you could hide this in
the box of the Christmas tree quite
easily you can get a case for this in
fact that's how I actually first saw it
was released I saw the tweet about the
case where other than the actual device
so yep they're cases available probably
cost more than the actual device great
so I might go and get my cell phone
you'll be lucky that also there we've
all gone so yeah yeah no it seems it
very very popular they seem to have sold
out of all the ones I've made I'm sure
they'll be making more and they'll be
available again soon
and it's very very difficult for people
who go into a bad place and use a card
because if if you complain to your bank
then the strip club owner will just say
we was with four girls